les législatives une élection de plus en
plus boudée par les français ils ont des
iphone des promesses qui ne tiennent
jamais donc ça sert strict de barrère
1958 premières élections législatives
sous la vème république
les français sont appelés à choisir
leurs députés et déjà au premier tour
l'abstention est importante grande
journée d'élection les abstentions à ce
premier tour se sont élevées à près de
23 %
22,8 % exactement soit plus d'un
électeur sur cinq
1962 l'abstention augmente au premier
tour 31 de 8 3% puis baisse et stagne
jusqu'en 1978 en 1981 après la
dissolution de l'assemblée nationale les
législatives se déroulent juste après la
présidentielle c'est une première sous
la vème les français boudent les urnes
29,1 % d'abstention au premier tour on
constate depuis le début de sa galerie
que chaque fois qu'il ya une séquence
associant une élection forte comme un
référendum ou une présidentielle et
l'élection législative dans le sillage
une bonne partie de ceux qui votent la
première fois ne reproduisent pas leur
comportement la seconde considérant que
l'essentiel a été fait
sept ans plus tard en 1988 nouvelle vie
solution de l'assemblée nationale
nouvelles législatives et même constat
l'abstention s'accroît encore 34 3%
premier tour pourquoi ce taux aussi
élevé les journalistes font encore appel
aux mêmes experts pour répondre à la
question les électeurs s'accommode mal
de ce système binaire de l'obligation
d'avoir à choisir droite contre gauche
et gauche contre droite et ça continue
1997 elle s'élève à 32 % les français
déçus par la classe politique ne se
déplacent toujours pas de député
précédent en quatre ans je n'ai pas vu
une fois dans un rayon de trois
kilomètres autour d'ici à partir de 2002
le calendrier électoral change les
élections législatives se déroulent
juste après les présidentielles et
l'abstention au premier tour explose 35
26% en 2002 puis 39 6% en 2007 avec à
chaque fois les mêmes arguments france
perdra la majorité donc je pense que les
jeux sont faits tant qu'il n'y aura pas
deux
de vrais changements qu un autre art ça
m'intéresse pas de hauteur en 2010 cette
année des dernières législatives
l'abstention a battu un record au
premier tour 51 3% des français ne se
sont pas déplacés pour voter du jamais
vu sous la vème république
ce record sera-t-il battu cette année
réponse après le premier tour le 12 juin
[Musique]